Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Io sono una stilista di moda e penso
che vi aspettiate qualche consiglio
sulle tendenze primavera estate 2014,
orli, trucchi per come
snellire la figura.
Bene, niente di tutto questo!
La moda per me è tutt'altro,
per me è stata
il mezzo di comunicazione
con cui raccontare la mia storia,
esattamente come in una storia
io ho strutturato
le mie collezioni,
di una storia le mie collezioni
hanno la struttura narrativa
e gli stessi principi compositivi,
dunque una trama, uno svolgimento,
un'ubicazione di tempo e luogo,
personaggi e protagonisti.
È per questo motivo
che ogni sfilata è preceduta
da un urlo di donna,
è una registrazione degli anni '60
di un'artista haitiana
che riproduce l'urlo
d'entrata in guerra,
il richiamo alle armi,
dice "rassembler",
concentrazione, riunione.
È il momento prima
della sfilata, anche se di norma
la sfilata è un atto estremamente
..così, di intrattenimento, di svago,
nel mio caso non lo è,
dunque chiedo al pubblico
di darmi attenzione,
di essere presenti
non solo con gli occhi,
ma di darmi una presenza reale,
perché per preparare quella collezione
io paradossalmente mi sono
dovuta spogliare,
mi sono denudata
per rivestire i miei modelli.
l'urlo che precede ogni sfilata
è questo:
[Audio dell'urlo]
La storia che racconto,
come vi dicevo, è la mia,
dunque è una storia che inizia
a Roma, dove sono nata,
da un padre torinese biondo
con gli occhi verdi
e da una mamma haitiana color ebano.
Nonostante tutti i loro sforzi,
nonostante abbiano potuto
mandarmi nelle migliori scuole
e farmi frequentare
i migliori milieux,
tutto questo non è servito
a salvaguardarmi e a proteggermi
con l'impatto traumatico
che una società totalmente non preparata
a una famiglia multirazziale
negli anni '80 ha avuto su di me.
Non vi racconterò gli episodi tristi,
gli episodi di banale intolleranza
che in un ambiente "bene"
possono essere più barbaramente
dolorosi che altrove,
bensì userò un esempio molto chiaro
ed esemplificativo,
vi parlerò del mio esame di maturità.
Allora, io sono totalmente una frana
in tutte le materie scientifiche,
ma proprio zero zero!
Però, facendo un rapido
calcolo di percentuale,
essendo brava, io, in italiano,
storia, letteratura,
lingue, latino, non mi possono bocciare.
Mi presento, primo anno
di commissione mista,
presidente esterno, do un documento,
dunque il presidente
aveva il mio documento davanti a sé
e inizio la mia esposizione.
Iniziano i primi complimenti
da parte della commissione
"Complimenti signorina,
come parla bene l'italiano,
meglio degli italiani" ho detto
"Guardi, sono nata a Roma,
sono italiana",
"Ah!". Continuo l'esposizione
e continuano i complimenti.
Al che mi domandano le materie
scientifiche, scena muta!
"Signorina, almeno una cosa!",
"No, niente, guardi,
non saprei proprio da dove iniziare",
"Ah, va bene, però guardi,
lei parla italiano così bene,
ce ne fossero di italiani
con una tale proprietà di linguaggio!".
Sentite come ho risposto
"Grazie mille!", per non perdermi.
E questo è come
ho passato la mia maturità,
non certo
per la mia preparazione eccelsa,
ma per l'impreparazione altrui
e questo a me
capita tutti i giorni: "Ciao,
di dove sei?", "Italiana",
"No, dai, veramente,
di dove sei?", "Italiana".
Anche se all'inizio può far ridere,
alla lunga il fatto
che vengano messe in dubbio
le vostre sicurezze anagrafiche
ad una bambina, adolescente,
in seguito una donna,
può iniziare ad essere
un elemento di disturbo.
Quando poi questo è successo
a mio figlio maggiore,
tre anni fa, mio figlio
è la mia testa, è uguale a me
nonostante un padre
dalla carnagione latte,
è uguale alla sua mamma, per fortuna.
Entriamo da un fioraio:
"Ma che bel bambino, di dove sei?",
"Romano",
"No dai, veramente, di dove sei?",
"Sono italiano!",
"Ma non sei... italiano italiano!",
"Ma io sono italiano
una volta sola!"(Risate)."
In quel momento ho avuto un flash:
dopo trent'anni
non è cambiato assolutamente nulla,
siamo ancora fermi allo stesso punto,
questo non è possibile.
Io ho preso mio figlio,
perché lui non avesse
o non dovesse patire
quello che ho passato io,
e gli ho detto:
"Facciamo un gioco, ogni volta
che ti chiederanno la tua nazionalità,
non dare
la risposta banalissima, italiano,
che è la verità: no,
inventatene una, canadese,
islandese, vieni dal Pakistan!".
Lui ha iniziato a fare cosî
e ogni volta gli hanno creduto.
L'altro giorno vedevo
che brigava per capire
dove fosse Honolulu,
per dire che veniva da là.
Dunque, quando noi parliamo
di ius soli... ma quale ius soli!
Il nostro grande ostacolo
non è a livello legislativo,
le pastoie burocratiche verranno dopo,
l'ostacolo è negli occhi,
nello sguardo di chi ti dice
"tu non sei italiano,
tu non puoi essere italiano",
è più lo ius oculi che noi chiediamo,
no ius soli,
quello verrà poi.
Io poi ho iniziato la mia carriera,
ho iniziato come indossatrice
dopodiché non era quello
il mio ruolo, ho iniziato a fare
le prime collezioni sperimentali
e sfogliando Vogue vedo
il bando per partecipare
al context patrocinato
da AltaRoma e Vogue Italia
Who Is On Next, mando la mia
partecipazione, emozionatissima:
bocciata!
Secondo anno, rimando
la mia partecipazione
e regolare arriva la seconda bocciatura.
La terza volta ho pensato:
"Forse è capace
che più che la giuria,
sia io a sbagliare qualcosa,
forse devo presentare
qualche cosa di più vero,
di unico, e quello che io ho
di unico è la mia storia,
le mie radici". Dunque presi
una camicia di mio padre
che stava a simbolizzare appunto
le radici europee,
le radici paterne, la fattura
perfetta della camiceria italiana,
e la stoffa wax che rappresenta
le radici africane di Haiti.
Haiti è l'isola di mia mamma,
la prima repubblica nera
indipendente al mondo
e l'isola dei Caraibi più nera di tutte.
Le misi insieme
e iniziai il mio racconto,
un racconto fatto di dodici look,
che - la mia mentore
che è diventata poi, ma
quella che prima consideravo strega
perché mi aveva bocciato due volte,
disse: "Adesso sì, Stella,
questa sei tu, adesso il racconto
è sincero, puoi passare".
Da lì ho iniziato questo
- questa filosofia, che è la filosofia
del Wax & Stripes
solo per simbolizzare il fatto
di unire due elementi opposti,
avrei potuto dire anche Black & White.
Il Wax, l'Africa; le righe, l'Italia.
Dunque il Nord e il Sud
del mondo, l'Occidente,
i paesi in via di sviluppo,
tutto dialoga in uno stesso look,
non è un look, non è un abito, una gonna
di cui io sto parlando adesso,
ma è del fatto di come
culture totalmente lontane,
totalmente opposte
possano dialogare
se trattate con conoscenza,
perché non posso,
prima di utilizzare qualsiasi stoffa,
la studio, studio la sua storia,
studio la sua provenienza,
anche perché fra trama
e ordito di una stoffa
si può scoprire di un paese
molto più di quanto Wikipedia
ci possa dire e da qui
sempre Simonetta Gianfelici,
grazie all' ITC,
l'International Trade Centre,
l'Agenzia delle Nazioni Unite
per i progetti di moda etica,
mi hanno portato in Burkina Faso.
In Burkina, questi sono sempre
modelli della collezione,
vedete c'è sempre l'elemento italiano
e l'elemento materno.
Not Charity, Just Work,
in Burkina ho conosciuto
queste donne nei villaggi,
nei villaggi fanno tutto loro,
dal lavoro, dall'educazione dei figli
all'educazione scolastica,
preparano il cibo
La loro giornata è perfettamente
organizzata e con un'enorme dignità
tessono a mano, adesso dirlo così,
che una stoffa è tessuta a telaio a mano
non sembra gran cosa,
ma se io vi dovessi far vedere
che ogni millimetro di una stoffa
è un passaggio manuale,
è una grandissima cosa,
è come se io vi dicessi
lavorare a tombolo è veramente un'arte,
e queste donne mi hanno fatto
scoprire le loro stoffe
che per me sono state
un'enorme sorpresa,
anch'io riesco a stupirmi ancora,
perché se adesso io vi chiedessi:
"di questi look,
uno maschile, uno femminile,
quale pezzo è veramente africano?",
sono sicura che il 99%
di voi sbaglierebbe.
Qual è secondo voi il pezzo africano,
non so, della donna?
È il capo spalla.
E il trench, per l'uomo.
Questi sono della tradizione centenaria
del Burkina Faso.
È bellissima la capacità, ancora,
di stupirci
che il mondo ci può proporre.
Dunque, teniamo gli occhi aperti.
Io oggi, dopo tanto tempo, ho capito
che non saranno più sguardi dubbiosi
a mandarmi
in crisi di identità,
perché il mio spazio me lo sono creato,
la mia identità io so qual è,
però vorrei che mio figlio
potesse smettere di giocare
al gioco delle nazionalità strampalate,
prima che questo gioco
smetta di divertirlo,
ma per far questo lui
ha bisogno di tutti i vostri occhi,
di tutti i vostri sguardi,
gli stessi sguardi
che fino adesso non sono stati
in una direzione,
possano stupirsi e cambiarla,
la direzione.
E possiamo farlo in qualsiasi momento,
non credere alle apparenze
è il motivo di cambiare
e se ci crediamo,
possiamo iniziare anche adesso.
Signori, attenzione prego.
[Audio dell'urlo]
Grazie.
(Applausi)